Ten years ago, few could have guessed that
five friends and a panda would capture the
hearts and attention of millions.
But the dudes of Dude Perfect have done just
that.
Even though they're Internet famous, not everyone
knows the Dudes behind the Perfect.
Whether you're a hardcore fan or just getting
into the online antics of Dude Perfect, here's
everything you need to know.
Cory Cotton, published author
Not content with mere Internet stardom, Dude
Perfect founding member Cory Cotton is also
an author.
In 2011, Tyndale House published his debut
self-help book, Go Big: Make Your Shot Count
in the Connected World.
In it, Cotton charts the course Dude Perfect
took from being a group of college kids to
becoming Internet sensations.
He also provides tips and pointers for other
would-be Internet conquerors.
And if anyone knows how, it’s these guys.
They're charitable Dudes
Just because he's a young guy riding a wave
of Internet millions, don't think Cotton has
let it all go to his head.
He and the rest of the group have made a point
of giving back.
They've aligned themselves with both Charity:
Water and Compassion International, as they
all feel they should do something more than
provide entertainment.
As Cotton put it:
"We have this platform, and we're always thinking
of the best ways to use it."
Charitable works are an excellent place to
start.
Cody Jones is a dad
Even in a whirlwind of media activity, the
Dudes still make time for their personal lives.
Not only are three of the guys married, but
in June 2016, Cody Jones took to Twitter to
announce the birth of his daughter.
It's a good thing they inked that TV deal
with CMT, because babies are expensive.
And if throwing up in buckets on cable TV
pays for your kid's college fund, so be it.
“Ha Ha, No, No”
They're honorary Globetrotters
Back in 2011, the guys in Dude Perfect began
a friendly rivalry with the original trickshot
masters, the Harlem Globetrotters.
The two teams met up at the Ranch for a game
of Horse.
The Dudes managed to impress the Globetrotters
with their signature super large fishing pole
shot, earning an invitation to become a part
of the team during their 2015 draft.
No word on whether or not the Dudes accepted
the offer.
International attention
Dude Perfect's attention isn't just limited
to just the US.
The group's tricks are so amazing that they've
caught the eyes of overseas outlets, such
as The Telegraph in the UK.
In their article, the Brits question not only
the authenticity of one of the group’s trick
shots, but they cast doubt on the entire enterprise.
According to the 2009 article, the members
of Dude Perfect remain "elusive," despite
intense media interest.
Sounds like someone's upset they didn't get
an interview.
The authenticity debate became so heated that
the folks at Good Morning America had experts
look at some of the videos to see if any were
manipulated.
“Are they real, are they fake.
We have computer analysts looking at them”
Predictably, the experts came up with nothing,
but that doesn't mean the speculation has
ended.
Famous fans
The Dudes have attracted an impressive fanbase,
including celebs such as Tim McGraw, Odell
Beckham Jr., and Dale Earnhardt Jr.
“Ahhh, Oh that’s cold”
The stars not only enjoy their videos, but
have asked to appear in them.
Even everyone's favorite Ant-Man, Paul Rudd,
wanted to take part in some of the fun.
The secret of the panda
The identity of the Dude Perfect panda is
one of the biggest mysteries in entertainment.
Well, okay, one of the biggest mysteries on
YouTube.
There's some speculation that it's an NYU
student named Dorian Marie, who wears a panda
suit to bring joy to the people of New York.
But that's the problem.
He's in New York, and Dude Perfect is based
in Texas.
It looks like the face behind the mask could
be one of those things the public never discovers.
Like The Stig from Top Gear, or how Steven
Seagal managed to keep a perfect ponytail
in all those early '90s action movies.
Expiration Date
Though they're having a good time now, the
Dudes eventually want to do other things.
In June 2015, Tyler Toney told The Kernel:
"We don't want to be 40-year-olds on YouTube
doing basketball shots."
But don't worry, it doesn't mean they'll disappear
from the public eye entirely.
Toney went on to say that he and the guys
want to continue entertaining, just differently.
Maybe they can turn their attention toward
training the next generation of Dude Perfectionists.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you want to know about Dude Perfect...